want to let you guys know that I will be
performing March 7th at the Castle
Theatre in Maui Hawaii or Kahului kau
lui
those tickets will go on sale Tuesday
February 11th at 10 a.m.
Hawaiian time so Aloha Mahalo gang Gallo
I'm really excited about that need a
vacation
today's guest is really the Patrick
mahomes of creativity he's a professor
at the University of Connecticut
he's written countless books including a
creativity 101 it is Professor James
Kaufman
[Music]
we're supposed to learn when somebody
has like a sharp object if ever I was
getting like some back stuff done and
guys like a needle this big and he
starts deciding to talk politics I'm
just like I'm nodding him smiling at
everything he says I don't care what he
said you know I can read all the way in
mind yeah right now what you could be
saying anything you want and as long as
you have like a blade this big I'm on
your side
yeah dr. James Kaufman who wrote the
really is one of the I mean you're kind
of like a little bit of the Sacajawea of
creativity kind of the white male second
Julia in a way I've never been called
that I you're like Lois aunt
some might say Forrest Gump okay I'll do
that but III go I've been very lucky
I've gotten to ask a whole lot of
interesting questions and it's a field
that's just starting to kind of take off
and it sounds kind of silly the idea of
studying creativity yeah but some of the
stuffs really intuitive and some of it
not necessarily what you think when you
say it's a field that's just starting to
take off like cuz recently I was I was
actually talking to my niece and I said
imagination right and she goes what is
it is it a is it on your phone and she
thought it was an app and it shook me to
my core I was like oh man it made me
think like Oh creativity is is dying you
know that it's not that it's not like a
new that there's nothing really new
there it's not like a you know like a
seeded forest as much as maybe I used to
think it was or is it that we're just
being creative in different ways cuz on
one hand yeah probably if you gave your
niece like you ever play like though
with those old like refrigerator boxes
or like just oh yeah it's a huge make a
bad layer of Noah's Arden Amistad or
something like on one hand yeah probably
if you gave her hey here's this huge
cardboard box do what you want so what
why I giving this me
but she might also be able to me make a
video do you any of this study using the
phone write to me you saw that do you
use to consume or create and there's
nothing wrong with consuming I mean I
love watching stuff and listening and
stuff but if you're also using it to
create I feel like the forest isn't
quite dead yet mmm yeah I worry
sometimes that I mean especially with
the phone I mean even with you know mine
is an example of just the alarm going
off like there's so many interruptions
these days
specifically with my phone - how much it
interrupts my thought processes you know
and even my sleep I brought interrupts
every process it seems like there's a
there's a call there's an email there's
a I mean it definitely seems like these
days there's a lot more interruptions
whereas creativity needs to meet more of
like a bed to kind of like you know
creativity it seems like you need some
time you got to get tangled up in the
sheets you know oh yeah it's what we
sometimes called flow that moment when
you are creating and you're engaged and
it's like you forget where you are and
that's one like five hours pass and
you're like I haven't even for the
entire day and of course if the phone
buzzes that takes you out of it it's why
when I'm trying to actively write and do
something I'm actually using like full
brain turn off phone sometimes even
disable Wi-Fi and I can't get away with
it too long I mean right we live in a
world where we get 400 emails a minute
and I got two kids and oh yeah
we have a question that so they came in
right here we had this question in my
name is max and I was wondering if dr.
Kaufman could maybe go into a little bit
of detail about what flow state is and
maybe ways to achieve them because I've
heard a lot about them but sometimes I
just have a bit of trouble achieving
that flow state so if you could
experiment I'll be great thank you a lot
of flow state junkies out there you know
people want that flow state I it's
intoxicating feeling people who I mean
you can get it other ways than just
creating a lot of people who are in the
mountain climbing or running the runners
hives it's not horribly different mm-hmm
the best way to enter flow is to do
something creative that's a little bit
challenging if it's too hard you're just
gonna go screw it I can't do this and if
it's something that's routine or too
easy it's gonna be simple like if you're
playing the piano and you kind of play
you know and if you just if you're doing
chopsticks you're not you're not
invested but then everybody say okay
Theo here's this like Rachmaninoff
symphony or something play it you're not
gonna have to do you're not gonna
interview me might be able to get a
melody but it's not gonna connect with
you it's always that slight challenge
and as you get better and you kind of
keep matching it you gotta up the
challenge
it's it has to be something that you
care about that you have passionate
about I mean just one of the first
things that I tell my students is what
are you interested in like forgetting
about the word creativity the word
creativity freaks people out now I teach
a class several classes on creativity
and one of the things I do is I haven't
do this big creative project and that's
it in terms of the rules you got some
students they are just thrilled they're
running with it like by the third day
they're all man I could do this and this
and there are other students who are
careful like if the assignment was cut
off your little finger they would have
gone that option Wow because that's more
definite that's more obvious yeah but be
creative it can mean anything and people
sometimes think well I'm not creative
and then they just shut it off and yet
you start talking what what are you
interested in what do you like doing and
then you work on that you play from that
okay and you just keep going in that
passion in that what are you interested
in it doesn't mean you're gonna be
necessarily good at it but creativity
isn't just about the outcome isn't just
about
reaching a certain level of creativity
that's always great but it's not always
about creating something certainly when
you first start off it can just be in
your head it can be an idea as long as
it has some type of meaning to you like
a business to random thought okay now
but let's say I mean okay actually if I
could ask like how do you get like for
your last comedy special like how are
you writing it how what was your process
yeah the process is you know I take
things from life that I thought were
funny or things that made me laugh and
then you know I started to expound on
them on stage then I would write them
down into Word documents and sometimes
go back and read through the document
when I was feeling pretty good and like
adding some stuff that I thought was
funny or adding things I wanted to try
and then I would go back onstage do it
again and just kind of keep kind of
swimming in that circle until I felt
like it was just kind of done at a
certain point my brain I choose not to
work on things anymore because it's just
like to me they're done there's nothing
else there could be a lot more to do if
I were somebody else
but for me it's like this is as far as
this bit or this area or this story or
world is going to go so I think that was
kind of the process I think is that a
process yeah yeah and one way of
thinking about it is that all the
initial stuff that things that you
remembering happening that we're funny
even this stuff before you remembering
it what is happening where maybe it
something funny you said or you saw or
you're thinking well if that had
happened it would have been funny and
then you're remembering it three days
later some of that stuff is going to
stay in your mind and your in develop it
and you'll try it out
other stuff will be there and you'll
think about it and you'll consider it
and there's not funny enough not enough
I can do with that yeah it's not enough
for me sometimes it's like it's not
creative enough for me I feel like like
somebody also it might be good for them
but this doesn't fit
maybe exactly my tastes you know for
what I find to be funny like when you
were first starting out you probably
means if you were like me or anybody
your hit ratio wasn't as good yeah you
know see you just okay light I bet that
could be funny and maybe trying it out
and you learn okay this works this
doesn't or this could really work that
process like from like what's up here in
your head to what you're actually saying
you share with another person that
that's kind of like this personal
creativity idea and that's something
that everybody else can theoretically
think it sucks it's hopefully you get
better and you can connect with other
people because that's so much of what
creativity is about where when you're
onstage there's an audience and it's
almost this interactive and you're
reading it then it gets to be what we
might call everyday creativity but at
your point much higher expert level
creativity professional refined for sure
I refine I like that because you've done
it so many times and you kind of are
familiar with a little bit of the dance
you know you know once you get out there
with the audience you know yeah it's
funny you can almost something like
playing an instrument after a while you
know it's like okay these are the notes
that I know and this is the reaction and
it's going to become sort of this circle
and it frees you up to try more things
because like you know okay this is the
stuff that I'll set the table if you
know while I'm working on it and that
some of you can almost go on autopilot
while your brains still going ahead able
to work in something work in an audience
reaction yeah that's interesting yeah
it's like you're almost like on all like
an Tesla whenever you can just be
cruising you know and sometimes you can
just touch the wheel every now and then
you know like you can yeah it's like
you're driving but every now and then
you you can it's almost like you can go
off the course without even but you're
staying on course a little bit you know
at the same time once you get to kind of
the cruise control of the of the of your
set you know is it hard to be creative
like
I'm thinking like sometimes on stage I
find easier opportunities to be creative
if I don't know if it's because of the
fee of how my day is going how I'm
feeling my comfort level
fear even is it harder to be creative
from a place of fear it's a good
question so if you look at okay what
type of emotion does your creativity
come from a lot depends on the type of
creativity so let's say that you're
feeling good you're more likely to get
the initial boost so the first minute or
two you're going to come up with more
ideas but you're gonna be okay with it a
little earlier so it whether it's on
stage in the moment or whether you're
still kind of brainstorming if you're
feeling happy or you're just excited or
just in a good mood it'll be good at
first but then it's like okay that was
good
if you're upset whether it's sadness
could be anger fear it'll take you
longer to kick in mmm but you won't get
satisfied as easily you're gonna keep
plugging away and so much isn't it
depend on what your goal is
like if you're aiming to get a routine
that is just as good as it can get and
you're still exploring it and it's worth
okay I'm gonna take eight minutes doing
this a bit and some of its gonna be a
little bit slow and maybe it'll be a
moment when I'm worried about losing the
audience but I'm gonna get something
that I can really work with and it'll be
better and connect better then fear or
anger or just kind of just being bummed
that's okay if you're okay I got a five
minute set I just got to go out boom
done happier is probably better hmm
right I see so if its long-term a fear
and anger can almost drive you harder to
get to stay resilient to find a place to
find more opportunity for creativity all
the longer-term
it's a question mark in that one of the
things that creativity is so good
it is it helps us cope with these type
of negative emotions mmm yeah I noticed
that sometimes I'll be in a bad movie -
my brain will think up something that's
kind of funny for me and then I will
feel better you know it's almost like
it's like a gift or something that my
brain gave me like to help out you know
it really is and people like we had this
image or stereotype of our creative
people are crazy or you know this image
of the mad genius or whatever I mean and
whether or not that's true and then
that's something like scientists enjoyed
arguing about we can use our creativity
to if we are feeling depressed anxious
creativity can distract us which can be
amazing
creativity can help us kind of organize
our thoughts there's this idea called
cognitive load which is kind of a weird
term but it's just how much crap is
upstairs in your head
Oh God and you know you always have
those kind like this monologue and this
recurring thought and all this stuff
yeah
and having browsers open on a computer
kind of you got too much open I mean
just like a computer your brain is like
okay I'm still working on this and still
working on this and still worried about
this what creativity can do is that it
can connect a lot of this stuff into a
narrative into a story it's why people
who journal ernet or blog they're
actually better off physically and
mentally mmm because they get a lot of
it out yeah it doesn't necessarily mean
you want to be like exposing our heart
and these are my worst fears no cuz like
Shakespearean type of like that nods
yeah because then you also run the risk
if you're almost like ruminating and
overthinking and then you end up kind of
getting sucked into this it's kinda like
half after a breakup a really bad break
I mean you want to allow yourself time
to be able to just curse Neil oh yeah
get rid of it but if it's six months
later and you're still this was her cell
phone number and all that and you yeah
standing on her porch petting a cat
that's what I did once
six months later she I don't even know
how long later
I don't want to think about it I soon
assess and it brought it up but yeah
it's uh yeah at that point you're not
yeah you're just ruminating on it's
gonna be hard for anything new - is it
hard for new stuff like is there a best
time for to create like four new things
to come out of us you know is there a
best time I mean say if we're using the
definition of that creativity is
something like a new a new thought idea
like our our most whimsical sort of way
of well I don't know what's the best
definition do you think I mean there's a
lot of definitions that seems like the
two things that we agree on pretty well
one is exactly that it has to be
something new the other ones it has to
be tasks appropriate that doesn't mean
socially appropriate that that you know
that does not mean inoffensive or
anything but it's at if you want to make
a creative meal mm-hmm then great you
can switch out ingredients whatever but
it has to be something that you could
eat if you decide I'm gonna make lasagna
but what would happen if I used
shattered glass instead of cheese that's
new that's really new not creative yeah
it's not fair to somebody yeah and like
you wouldn't even say oh that's a
lasagna that's just yeah that's glass
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah nice try I mean if it
were art that we're doing but if we have
to eat then you can't that's not very
creative which need about comedy is that
what's the task I mean just make
somebody laugh right make somebody laugh
make somebody think make somebody feel I
think it's expanding a little more these
days into also like make somebody feel
almost sometimes I think some of our
comedians have become a also I feel like
you'll get more people like you you also
get applause breaks for people being
able to to make people feel I think it's
always been think and laugh but I think
there's a little bit of feeling in there
these days as well yeah I find when I
look back on my own life it because the
only perception perception I have fully
as my own and so when I look back I find
I used creativity a lot of times
as like a defense mechanism but like as
a way like we didn't have a lot growing
up so I was like oh whoa I need to
always be able to think or do something
or say something that someone else isn't
going to do it was like almost like a
currency in a way it was like if I can
have creativity that can be a currency
because it like the wool does that make
any sense
Oh completely if you look at so much
this stuff that we value as an education
system as if we're hiring people you
know we look at test scores and grades
and all this stuff so some economic
status plays a role in that because if
you don't have access to books or a
computer I mean it's harder it's not
your creativity anybody can be creative
it doesn't matter if you're rich or poor
does it help if you're poor though I
feel like if you have everything then
you don't need to make anything up each
one of those questions if you're asking
me it's like the scientist then I'd have
to go well we haven't studied that
enough if you're asking me as a human
being yeah yeah I think it helps I think
that so much of creativity comes out of
necessity I mean if you always are
cooked dinner and you never have to cook
you're not going to figure out creative
ways to cook or creative ways to okay I
got to make eight dollars last for the
next two days for dinner or to use
ingredients to armor making my mom stuff
sometimes we didn't have something I
would use something else
you know we don't have flour I'll use
this I'll use epsom salts you know it's
like change it up just as a kid you're
thinking oh whatever looks the same so
then yeah you might get a butt whuppin
you know you might get beaten down but
but at least you start to create this
world in your head when you're like oh
this could be this you know a butterfly
could be like a you know a color Hawk or
something here's some guy right here
he's got an issue yeah sub dr. James is
because of Nate from New Orleans out
here bouncing bums and smoking
cigarettes in North Hollywood
my questions are both the oh I think
there's a correlation between creativity
and comfort like the more uncomfortable
you are the more creative you gotta be
to find that comfort
I know Thea when Marc Norman talked
about that a little last week on the
podcast and I'd like to get y'all
opinion on that thanks brah whoo that
and gang gang-bang Nate I hope he's okay
yeah that's it yeah so yeah is there a
correlation between creativity and
comfort certainly if we look at okay how
people think creatively there's a couple
of different aspects of it one of the
real big ones is idea generation getting
your ideas I think if you're too
comfortable you're not gonna be getting
a lot of ideas it's the same way that
like if you look at okay well what how
can you be more creative if you are
paralyzed by anxiety that's not good but
a little bit of anxiety a little bit of
that just slight discomfort I mean it
makes you think of more ideas makes you
think of more solutions you can't find
something to solve if you have if
everything your life is perfect yeah and
I think that there are other parts so
like if you're trying to if you're doing
revision if you're testing out material
not in front of a live audience but like
for a friendly audience then there are
times when okay I want you know you may
want to just be comfortable and I want
to sound the best or if you're filming
something but the raw generation for the
brainstorm you kind of want that little
bit of grittiness yeah that discomfort
that it almost seems like the like
creativity would come from a place like
that like if I had to you know if I was
in a cave or something like create like
creativity would be kept on like kind of
a magic place it seems like I mean we
need a reason to do stuff and it's a
perfectly good reason to entertain but
it's also to solve a problem to figure
it out too
you want something you can't get is just
going back to the stuff we're talking
about well if you know if you're growing
up poor and without resources
you got to be creative yeah you got to
be creative I was thinking yesterday
like I was thinking I was talking to a
friend and thinking about like living in
a city it like it limits like even like
the tall building is in everything and
and you know and being in more of
traffic and it limits like even just
what my view is constantly like I can't
even see that far and I can't even you
know I like the things I do see it's a
lot more cars and buildings then growing
up in a more of a rural area where you
could see like an open field where it's
like oh I could put something in that
field like your brain has time to like
you know there's just seems like there's
more of a canvas for your plate for your
brain to play with growing up in areas
where there's more space sometimes
physical space but then I guess that's
not necessarily true because you could
be a great artist that comes out of New
York City and it's one of those there's
always good things and bad things like
in LA you're surrounded by a network of
people like if you want to make an
entertainment you're gonna be in LA
maybe New York is a couple of places and
use all these resources yeah all the
idea of we co-create so often and you
needed yes we have technology and you
can Skype and zoom but just being in the
room and talking and if you're in
Montana it's harder to be in the room
yet you're also right in that nature can
inspire beauty inspires us and just
having more of a canvas having more of
something to fill up and if you can get
that type of network even not at a
professional level but if you are
wherever you are and you have the people
you can whether it's right with or try
business with or joke around with as
long as you have that connection with
people it should be okay do you feel as
like we move away I was thinking like do
you feel like as we move away from even
like for children like you we move away
from like writing with our hands and
into
you know pressing buttons on the
computer - right do you feel like that
like we might be going through like a
real I wonder what the effect that has
on our creative psyche or the creative
like template that we've grown up with
you know like to write or to use our
hands to create more use more clay
whereas now we use more um you might be
able to do something 3d design or
digital design I definitely think we're
losing something I think we're gaining
stuff because I think technology can do
amazing stuff but I also think there's
something about being creative with your
hands you know whether it's Legos you
know or play or just making a Styrofoam
cup for god sakes just anything you can
do stuff with the paper clips that has
less than intuitive appeal I mean now
there's an app that you can undoubtedly
link paper clips together and it doesn't
make it bad it's just different yeah
it's just different I wonder what that
effect is on us I guess is it effect the
fact if I'm not using my like my motor
skills attached does it start to weaken
like a part of me where one day my you
know my create whatever the core of my
creativity is in Sodom you'll just be
like an appendix or something in your
body that you don't need you know it
just makes you wonder sometimes I can
see certain parts of it it's the same
like with Google there's and other
search engines there's certain parts of
our critical thinking and certain parts
of our long-term memory that are kind of
getting worse is that bad
it's not good we need to improve for
example how to learn how to figure out
what sources are good right so we're you
know trying to figure out you know who
is a 17th president in United States and
we type it in okay boom we don't have to
remember that anymore right but we also
got to figure out okay well is this a
good source for that if it's just who's
president but let's say it's you know
even what's the good Mexican restaurant
around here right
was just something that airy and n was
just being placed by the company that
owns it and we have to build up
different skills sometimes we are
sometimes we're not I mean with social
media all this technology stuff all of a
sudden we can reach people in a way we
were never able to do I mean if you were
a stand-up comedian in the 40s and 50s
yeah you know you'd be going from Club
to club but if you weren't working with
one of the five or six big clubs which
meant networking connection right if you
didn't impress the one work two or three
studio executives who put you in a film
or they didn't have that many records
but have you cut a record you were prime
on the outside looking in nowadays you
can work and you can connect with people
and you can communicate directly to an
audience and I think that can be great I
think it can also be a little scary yes
for the ability to connect creatively
the ability to share creativity and get
it out there is really a it's at a
unprecedented space it's like kind of an
impressing at a level like even
SoundCloud for example like like
SoundCloud now a place or you know where
you know rappers and not even good
rappers can interact with each other
constantly but it's it's like a place
where everybody can be a musician but
does that mean that I wonder are we
really creating better musicians or do
we just have that everybody is a
musician now you know even if it's bad
like is it just you know like sometimes
we you create a stable and just because
everybody can now have a horse doesn't
mean that any of these [ __ ] you know
it just means everybody has a horse you
still might win a race yeah everybody's
not ready to race really to me the big
danger is is getting on stage too early
because then you're gonna get feedback
and sometimes that's great but it's a
question of can you handle having a
thousand people say you suck right
because some people are gonna go okay
I'm not a good rapper I'm not
I'm not funny and just give up other
people to go screw you I'm gonna make
you laugh and make you like this song if
you're an adult that's one thing but if
you're 12 yeah how many 12 year olds
have the resiliency to you know you suck
you suck or any of that stuff yeah it's
pretty wild because it used to be like
if you you shared a talent it was a
couple people at your school you know
who saw it and you saw their faces and
the teacher made them apologize to you
if they said made fun of you and it was
pretty much it was a world that you
could still kind of manage a little bit
you could say to your mom you know
Oh Tommy didn't like what I did you know
and his mom appalled you know and his
mom could call your mom or whatever but
now you walk out and you put it out
there and you know you know Larry you
know Larry Applebaum 7000 hit you up and
he's like you're going to hell or
something you didn't even and your music
wasn't even about hell and you're like
jeepers man and it's always there and
it's always there yeah I mean you
release a song or a routine when you're
14 and then you're 25 trying to do it in
it's still there yeah some guys like oh
hey remember I wrote 10 years ago I just
wanted to remind you again that you suck
you're like I mean I publish these
little tiny scenes you know I can
cranked out in people's garages
somewhere like comedy or stories or
horror fiction back when I was in my
teens thank god those are all long gone
I mean they're like lining bird cages
and they're I mean hopefully just you
know compost heap somewhere if if I was
having somebody who Hey look you wrote
this when you were 15 Oh God I would
yeah we never write again it's true huh
it's interesting in the memory the
memory of the Internet what's available
with like the vault that's there I
wonder sometimes like um I do notice
that it is tougher to be creative I feel
like they're more comfortable that that
you get I feel like your brain just not
your brain but I don't know it's just
there's something more romantic or more
like inspirational about having to
achieve something even just in the past
year of my own life and having some more
success it's been for when I've been
tired but for - I've been sometimes I'm
like man am i it really challenges makes
me wonder how how am I still gonna
manage my creativity and still make sure
that I stay creative because that's the
thing that I love the most about
anything was like making a joke or
making like a joke was always if it was
if it was in the moment you know it was
like oh that's something that's
unprecedented you know it's just here
and it's there and it's done and it's
gone and we can never go back to that
exact moment which is the one thing that
I loved about calm that I loved about
comedy the most is just that it's just
that split-second that's that spark of
when a joke happens and you just can't
replicate it I'm asking a question why
do you love comedy what makes you love
comedy what what makes you want to do
another routine movie special
Oh siq use me sorry sorry to interrupt
the episode I just have had a couple of
chips today's episode is brought to you
by better help better help will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist if you
thought about therapy and you're not
sure and you just kind of you're driving
in circles around your house or
something in you you keep calling the
cops on people in your family or
whatever that can change you can start
communicating with a therapist in under
24 hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help but is professional counseling
done securely online there's a lot of
range of expertise in better helps
counselor network I've used them myself
I was running late for something one day
and I lost my mind and I had to pull
over and had to contact my better help
therapist
Audra was her name and she and I got at
it on FaceTime right then and there I
was able to get some peace of mind the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log in your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed better I want you
to start living a happier life today
and so do I visit better help.com Theo
that's better help calm slash Theo and
join the over half a million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10% off your first
month at better help calm slash Theo if
you need help get help and now back to
the episode I think surprised the
element of surprise I think the fact
that people don't know what's going to
happen and that you know so I think
there's probably some control may be in
there something
and just getting to make people feel
good just knowing that people are going
to like they don't know but you're red
they're really gonna have fun let's say
that you have two gigs your next Netflix
special and they're paying you three
times as much and small comedy club that
you know you're getting barely enough to
cover your gas money do you prepare
differently for them yeah how if I may
help ya prepare differently like me for
the Netflix special I'll probably really
rehearse and go through things see what
I'm gonna wear you know have a little
bit more of a Purdue production you know
mindset whereas the other one I'll just
make sure that I get there a few minutes
before I have to go on stage are you
more likely to experiment with either
one and what you say we try out yeah
probably more ocular to experiment at
the smaller venue club I mean the way
that both from the research but also
kind of just basic human being as long
as you keep varying you're gonna keep
that passion you're gonna keep the
creative need because you're gonna still
have that discomfort you're gonna still
have that feeling of locating it's like
I mean I know you just you know you I
know you just got signed not just to the
new Chris Pratt movie all this stuff and
like that's a certain both level
exposure but less freedom as long as you
make sure and I know you're going to
that you still have these places where
you have that freedom mm-hmm you do and
you do both obvious just keep it even as
long as you don't give this up you're
not gonna lose it mm-hmm it's when
people don't do this and it's hard when
this thing is paying so much money and
this is the thing that everybody's
watching and seeing and maybe you know
50 people are seeing this five hundred
thousand are seeing this it's tempting
okay I wanted to 95 percent of this yeah
as long as you don't get this up because
and that's the stuff that got you in the
first place that's where you're still
gonna be okay I want to try something
new out I want to surprise these people
right in a way that I mean you know yeah
no I love that so it's yeah cuz it's
almost yeah I love that I think that's
perfect it's like so funny it's cuz it's
just some of the exact same stuff I need
to hear right now
and here's another white guy with a
question here yeah what's up Nick this
is Nick from Long Beach California I've
got a question for the professor coming
in today so I'm a musician and I have
been for most of my life music has
always flowed out of me really easily I
would stay up late until you know 2 3 4
in the morning just writing and
composing but when I hit about 28 and
I'm 30 now that kind of stopped real
life started to get in the way and that
creative flow drained out of me and I
don't know where to find it again I'm
sure there's a some kind of chemical
reason or cause for that but I just
wanted to know if that's common and what
I can do to fix or combat that Gang Gang
Gang bro it's a great question I request
a vulnerable question - thanks Nick and
I mean if something I can identify with
I mean I always wanted to be a writer
and I wrote plays and I kept doing that
through grad school when you're not
really supposed to like a playwright
yeah I've been I've been lucky I mean I
I had a lot of my short plays produced
places I mean nothing anybody would
heard of right but a playwright yeah
it's like how do you even unless you're
going to ancient Rome or like you know
stratford-on-avon were you even gonna
get a gig and so I did
but you know my day job which thankfully
ended up loving but once I got the
full-time job I got married you know I
got kids I stopped writing plays for
about 14 15 years I've only recently
tried to get back into it I mean a lot
of it is at a certain point your real
life starts creeping on you
have to make a living you have to
fulfill certain obligations you have
people who depend on you all of a sudden
I mean if it's just you and you're and
you're single you know kids there's a
certain freedom I have two boys I adore
him you know but if I were to suddenly
quit my job that's not just me right not
just affecting you
yeah life comes in it's it's it's why I
think so many times I attach creativity
to the young too like when you have that
nest around you to when you have just
you're not thinking how is there gonna
be food tonight you're not thinking
where is the milk how who to put in gas
none of those things are part of your
wheelhouse
and then as you get out into the world
more you're like okay I have to survive
I have to take care of myself you know I
may have to take care of others
you won't even just saying there's three
things right there that's not theirs no
yeah there's no room for Crete there's
not a lot of room for I mean you might
be able to cut your son's ego when it's
a star but outside of that you're not
doing a lot of arts and crafts and yet
here's a kicker like he knows more about
music right now than he ever has in his
life it takes knowledge and experience
to really get to the next level and we
have a society this school system that
doesn't really value creativity it
values the test scores the grades do
this do that I mean I'm seeing this
right now with my youngest who is this
bright creative a little and a little
bit a little bit of a pain in the ass a
little bit of a little bit of an imp I
could guess I don't even know I mean and
sometimes the school isn't really
thrilled and you know we get these
emails or phone calls and it's just a
god and I mean heck my impulse is to
start going okay let's just let's just
tone it down a sure you know let's just
they say this just just do it by the
time that you're out of school by the
time that you know you're in college or
at a job you know it's not rewarded it's
not reinforced people say they want
creativity most don't they
want little creativity they want o
figure out a quicker or cheaper way of
doing this right
they don't want an idea that'll be well
we actually now maybe we should really
rethink our approach now this stuff none
of your teachers want to hear why
they're wrong I mean I love it but but a
lot don't though no which would honestly
welcome a lot of creativity because then
you're creating a lot of conversation
you know yeah definitely the more that
we are set in our ways about things and
the more that we leave things set around
us
and set things harshly around us which
happens a lot these days especially in a
lot of businesses because there's so
many the lawsuits are so many like you
can't veer off the beaten path you can't
even be creative you can barely even
speak you know without fear so for there
to be room for creativity sheesh that's
the first thing out of the door a lot of
times biggest advice give yourself an
hour a week you know where okay yes you
have all this crap you have to do and
you're tired and and you and you're
spending all this time on just survive
it keep yourself an hour a week turn
everything off and it's okay if you
don't produce anything it's okay like
again my thing is writing but when I
have writer's block which is a lot it's
okay to just read something you wrote
before and try to remember that mindset
it's okay to just helps a lot oh god yes
because you're reaching back to where
you were being creative or just type
words just to me when I'm trying to
write like more of my nonfiction easy
stuff I'll write the title in my name
and then I'll do a page break and I'll
put a placeholder for where like the
introduction goes and all of a sudden
month I'm on page five yeah hey I mean I
didn't read anything but there's a
feeling of okay I can do this I'm doing
something yeah I'm in this the table set
you know I remember remember when you
were young you would risk write your
name all the time I mean for like
probably the whole time I was in school
just kind of writing my name and drawing
it differently and adding something you
know or writing something draw
a picture of a hat or something you know
like you see your you always had a pin
you always had a you an immediate
element with the pen and paper and you
had to have it out in class to look like
you were doing something to him so you
were always there was just a half such a
half-second between yourself and
actually creating something and whether
it is drawn whether it's writing whether
it's whatever whereas in a laptop which
I mean most of my students have they'll
have their laptops out or their phones I
mean you're much more inclined be
opening up Instagram Twitter and there's
nothing wrong with that but you're more
likely be consuming and if you have like
30 percent of your brain that you're
focusing with you're probably not gonna
be doing something new and you'll be
where that okay well if I'm moving my
thumbs or looking down at my crotch the
professor's probably I figure out what's
going on yeah whereas if you're just
writing and taking notes and but then
you start writing something else or or
drawing I mean there's a certain
immediacy there's a certain you create I
mean you physically creating something
that feels more tangible I guess maybe
since it's right there as opposed to
like a laptop or something and it's done
is there I mean when I'm in my idea
phase I still want a pad of paper and
yeah you know it because if I want to
all of a sudden start drawing things in
relationship to each other I can yeah
and I know you can do that unlike
Microsoft whatever it screws up every
time I tried it to it and then I start
going into okay problem solving how do I
fix write next thing you know your whole
hours going you spend it listen yeah I
mean I hope he's gone and right and it's
like okay and then you're upset yeah I
mean how how many times I take four you
lose all you all your work when you it
crashes before you're like yeah yeah
it's to go back to what that young man's
question was I mean I think that was a
good suggestion to go back into what
you've done before because you were
creative then so I I noticed like I'll
make a gratitude list about five days a
week right in the morning and because I
I've struggled with trying to have
gratitude making sure that I have some
gratitude I feel it but I need to really
practice it and I want to feel it more
and so some some days um
I'm like man I I don't want to do this
so what I'll do I'll go back and just
read things oh I'm so thankful for this
friend of mine I'm thankful that you
know I have legs I'm thankful that I
could see you know different colors I'm
thankful you know for sharks I'm
thankful for this or that you know
plants or whatever you know different
you know different ways that people you
know people can walk backwards I'm
thankful for anything you know just and
then next thing you know my brain it's
like I don't know I'm just in a place
now where I'm like man I am thankful for
stuff I am grateful for things look at
all these things that wrote man it could
be a hundred pages of stuff and and then
my list is easier and then I even feel
what I've already was talking about I
wanted to feel gratitude I just I am
grateful instead of sitting there just
pining like I don't know if I'm grateful
today or not you know yet it's going
back to our work which was a starting
point before that we conquered
absolutely and you're always a little
better than you think because when you
first do it you probably are not as good
as you think but then you work on it and
you're remembering what you used to do
when you're probably very critical but
then you go back and you know maybe it
was more raw but you see who you what
you were thinking and it's a little
freeing yeah I mean listening to the
music that he they hate that he did oh
yeah five years ago does this listening
to it you know I mean listening to in
the car and I mean some part I mean like
part of me is a very hard time reading
my own stuff or I mean seeing myself or
watching myself
um but reminding yourself of if you're
not who you are creatively where you
want to be remind yourself of when you
were yeah ten versus Inuit that person
is there oh yeah and that person still
listening and paying attention and
thinking and has new melodies and and it
doesn't mean these are gonna be
brilliant melodies you know I mean there
are all these books you know how to be a
creative genius you know I can't tell
you that yeah because frankly most
people aren't but who cares
I mean when some ways everybody's
creative in some ways aren't they oh
absolutely it's the word genius that I
hate
oh yeah because yeah everybody wants to
be a genius everybody wants to be the
best with creativity I mean yes there
are some people who of course who are
creative geniuses but I love that you
think about your audience and that
audience it can be just you can be your
friends I mean it can be the person
you're doing something for I mean if
you're working on something you know
that you want to give to your girlfriend
to your mom you know I mean think of
hopefully not the same thing um yeah
sorry some areas that we got some select
areas out there where there is illegal
you know and you think about who is it
for a it kind of reinforces the
motivation but it also okay well her
favorite color is orange I'm gonna work
that inner oh she really likes
Chihuahuas and it kind of guides to work
you can be your own audience after you
do it I mean I'm just thinking about you
were talking about you have the ideas
and you try them out then you go back I
mean when you're reading or speaking the
ideas from a while ago you may not even
remember when you wrote it down no yeah
and it's almost like you're
collaborating with yourself in a weird
way yeah it is it's funny yeah and
thought about that exactly I just
recently started doing it like I was
having trouble so when I went back and
read and it made me feel so much better
and I was like oh man I'm I'm writing
down things that are great I can do this
this isn't and I have a lot in me I'm
like I'll look at all these different
things and it made me yeah it just set
the table so much differently inside of
me because I showed up with this dis
press tour to create right now you know
one of the things you were saying made
me think about like discount we're
constantly creating now you know it's
like we have to update we need an update
on our Facebook we need an update on our
Instagram we have to update we need new
we need content you know where it used
to be you would have something and maybe
like man how was your thing for a while
you know we got a question that came in
right here from a possibly young
Vietnamese fella who is he
it's your boys name from Denver I just
wanted to know what you guys thought
about creative overload sometimes I feel
like I want to create everything like
I'm trying to start a podcast I want to
make music
I want to animate my text and and do
video editing and I want to I want to do
everything but sometimes I just feel
like I gotta pick and choose what my
energy goes and I just want to know what
do you guys ever feel creatively
overloaded where you just you just want
to do all these different projects but
can't or do you guys just pick the
things that you feel most passionate
about let me know what you guys think
Thanks it's Zane signing off gang gang
gang gang it's a great question same
yeah maybe Russian uh you know that is a
great question won't you the doctor man
yeah I thought it was kind of similar to
what you just like yeah just all those
different we used to focus on one thing
now there's yeah and it feels that way
too doesn't it and certainly I mean I
feel creative overload I I always have
too many things that I want to do and
too many other things I have to do and
the thing about what his aim is talking
about is that sometimes they were in
different areas and it takes different
things to be creative in different area
yeah it takes some space between the two
sometimes I think I'm doing banking and
then I gotta you know I'll close my
Chase accounting and I'm supposed to
write a paragraph about something I need
a few minutes man yeah it takes
different knowledge it takes me you
can't practice the city is different
practices you know when I was younger I
was like okay I miss everything now I'm
older you know and one of the big
actually one of the big things was about
two years ago I had a heart attack no
way man and I was a lot bigger oh wow
lost weight I mean still big but you
know I think you look right sighs I
think you do a safari you like you do uh
you sir hunted dinosaur I would see you
doing those things James had probably
the first one eaten but then that's all
right
and elected maybe that delectable choice
you know and a little more tenderizer
while so did that a ja I mean what did
that he changed it because I was I
decided that there had to be a
particular reason for me taking it any
project I did I mean one big reason was
the passion to love that you know this
is something I love doing it's like
right now one of the books I'm doing I'm
a big theater geek and me and a composer
who zombie prom and a lot of really fun
musicals
Dana row we're finishing up this book on
creativity musical theatre for young
performers and just kind of conveying
all this how can be creative and it's
just fun we Skype every Wednesday and
it's one of the most fun I've had on a
project Wow
I do things to help folks I mean I love
mentoring students and so I'll just I
have a graduate students undergrad I'll
do stuff that is closer to their
interests that will help them advance in
the field because that to me that you
just be able to give back even if it
just a little bit is huge and I mean
third thing is more practically like
okay some things pay money and money is
a decent thing to have right but it's
not letting any of that certainly not
letting the money part overwhelm things
but it's not like her to make that I
mean you can't just follow your heart
because right because you also have to
survive it does become a balance you
know I'm just going back yeah it's like
it does yeah you have to balance it but
like you're saying that balance is
what's going to also keep you in a space
to be creative to want to stay
passionate yeah that overload is such a
big thing man it's like you got 19
things open going on you just agreed to
do something else because you want to do
it it sounds great and just you can
really get burnt out how do you make
choices
um I've gotten a little bit better about
saying no about things I mean really a
lot of times if I find if I'm
overthinking something too much then
it's not something that I wanted to do
so unfortunately I'm
extremely indecisive it's something that
I just I really struggle with it and it
sorry well it's hard to say no though
yeah or so we tend to be people pleasers
yeah I mean you're in a comedy you want
to make people laugh you know and sign
them no I can't do that but you know
when people to like me I want to like
myself you know so I'm not trying to
please them I'm trying to please myself
and between that pack of wolves it's a
yes it's a constant yes and there's so
many options and things to do now so
that's another thing it's like say you
make a to-do list of the things you had
like you said things I have to do and
then when I'm done with those things
that I would like to do so you get your
half twos out of the way your
requirements then you're left with a
list of things I'd like to do but then
today there's seven thousand things
trying to influence you and there's so
much other available content
it used to be yet it ride your bike to
your buddy's house to even look at his
diorama for 20 minutes you know and then
his mom me always hiding pornography
somewhere and beat everybody's butt but
now it's like you can you know you can
uh you can do anything you can order a
sheep's costume you can be playing
Legend of Zelda with set people from
China you can do anything you want and
it's right there so though and those
things are very addictive so for those
things to be sitting on top of the
things you would like to do every time
your passion projects and stuff and it's
a real battle because I mean you can't
be creating 24/7 it's exhausting your
time you know and so you have the mean
first it's just okay well I do want to
blow off steam and relax
you know and then what are the things
that are exciting enough to me that is
know most that same category that
working on this creating this thing is
the same level of fun as the really fun
thing that yeah whatever it is you enjoy
doing it may not be that probably isn't
creating I mean if you can find
something that you're working on that
you get that same level of passion
that's
even though this is brain work or its
emotion work or its requires fought an
effort I still want to do this even more
than just you know doing that they
allows me to zone out I mean that that's
a pretty nice sign that you're onto
something yeah that you're onto
something you really care about yeah so
it's hard it would be hard to say no to
things but it does get easier to do it
and then what I start to realize is
people appreciate it when I can
communicate a lot clearer you know it
really even though part of me is like I
don't want it to say this because I'm
going to upset them it's really people
just want to make the most use of their
time as well and to really be able to
communicate clearly and really just find
out yeah what's what is really
passionate for you you know sometimes to
your course and I was just hard to admit
to yourself cuz absolutely I mean if
you've ever I'm sure every but all of us
have worked on stuff that just your
heart wasn't into it and it was kind of
boring but you knew you had to do it I
mean yeah high school and beyond that I
mean I'll do like two minutes of on that
and then all three minutes on something
else and it'll keep coming back and I'll
be doing minute by minute by minute
until this 10 minute task will take me
like 4 hours because I hate it so damn
much yeah I mean if I think but why why
are we creative you know like what what
we need out of necessity probably
originally stuff we need you know it's
tough enjoyment I mean
oh yeah like if you want to say you're
in a man you're in Adam and Eve or
somebody or you know Larry and Janet or
whoever you believe in you know say you
know or Rachid and whoever you know Sean
trace or whatever whoever's in the
garden and the guy sees the girl walk by
he might try to do a magic trick or
something with a stick and a leaf or
something to try and get her attention
he's gonna be creative he's you know I
mean even in nature you see those little
lizards and stuff show off their
backbones and whatever you know they do
that where you got to put the bowerbird
there and they go and they final this
pretty stuff and they ya make like a
like a something pretty or they'll hide
a piece of food and they'll build stuff
around it
but some male bowerbirds learned we
don't need the piece of food we just
take a rock build over it and by the
time the female bowerbirds get to the
rock and they're going hey that's a wife
or though the male bowerbirds 10 miles
away going thank you yeah sayonara man
damn birds are wild but yeah it's so
yeah creativity because you want to get
something here's some people right here
decent group that's a beautiful group
look like nurses or something maybe
traffic with the photos up there were
cast also teachers possibly yeah it
could be teachers where lots of binders
yeah beautiful groups of ladies and a
gentleman right there
yeah are left-handed people more yeah
let's answer that for them a doctor
that one's easy no no the whole
left-brain right-brain you know no no
that matter no doesn't work that way
creativity is not a left brain thing
analytic reasoning is not a right brain
thing it's all way more complicated and
something that both of us to be trying
to understand for the next five hours
and not come to something but it's not
right brain left brain
I say yeah you always had people be like
oh well Daniels left brain you know
can't you know you don't know how to
play dodge ball or something like what
the hell does that have to do with
anything
yeah some people it's just like the most
simplest way to say things I guess
sometimes and it's I mean you can't
blame them no I mean it's like whenever
there's a new study out about creativity
people always forward it to me and it
will always be a quick and easy thing
you know you want to be more creative
try and it's you know a messy desk or
going for a walk or having some
chocolate and it's always well you know
I mean it probably wouldn't hurt but
it's not gonna make you all of a sudden
more creative I mean maybe it puts you
in a good mood you know we're talking
about you're in a good mood you might
come with more ideas yeah you're not
gonna suddenly be you know you know
who's a famous artist do the GOP's
newbie yep Picasso Charles oh yeah yeah
not gonna say yeah you're not gonna
suddenly be yeah I remember when I was
they said if you eat peanuts and raisins
together at the same time it'll make
your brain activate and you'll be able
to be more creative and I remember they
would give us that before at school that
some of the some of the parents would
bring bring them in little bags for the
kids and class if it was that easy I
mean I mean come on if you knew that
there was anything you could do that
would make you funnier you'd do it yeah
and the only thing I can do is practice
yeah is it the same with creativity than
you think yeah I mean if there was a
quick easy sexy solution of oh you want
more creative just blank I'd already be
a multi-millionaire because I would just
be doing that creativity is about
revision it's about figuring out what
you need to know and getting experience
with the domain and you know if you want
to be a writer reading other stuff if
you want to be a comedian you I mean
thankfully this part is more fun but you
got to watch a bunch of comedy I mean
there are certain rules so to speak even
if comedy where it's not oh I want to
break the rules you got to understand
them before you break them well now you
can watch comedy not even by watching
like you know comedian sets even just by
being in a lot of funny instances
watching other people be funny seeing
what works and what does in like I'll
see somebody do something sometime and
they don't even realize it I'm like oh
man that's such a unique way to be funny
that person isn't they don't even
realize what they're doing but sometimes
you meet people just the way they are
and the way that they talk or behave or
something is just extremely funny for
some reason it's like it's like the joke
is not that they're the joke personally
but just the way that they approach the
world is just it's like the setup is
already there so the punchline when they
say anything it's a punchline you know
going back to what you were talking
about with uh with education and how
they really do not they don't it's not
that they don't value I think teachers
really value creativity when they see it
but it's it's almost like they don't
have time to teach it or or it's just
not something that we value as a society
or it's just that we already have put
enough pressure on our education system
that has nothing to do with them you
know what do you think I think you're I
think you're in on some great stuff I
mean most teachers who I know they want
to encourage creativity I mean there's a
lot of this stereotype of Oh schools
kill creativity and all this stuff I
mean not really I mean most teachers
truly want their students to be more
creative usually they don't know how to
do it I mean when you get trained to be
a teacher there's no class on nurturing
okay there is it Yukon because we help
you know is not how do you nurture
creativity and it's not always intuitive
I mean so often the impulse is okay well
you know to give the gold star or the
reward and you know that can kind of
kill creativity pretty easily
so you've teachers who don't always know
and then teachers who may not trust
themselves to know it's creative even
though they probably know a lot more
than they think they do but then you had
the whole I mean the schools are judged
by the standardized test scores any
least standardized test scores I mean I
mean my first two years out of grad
school I worked for a testing company I
mean I I it's not that they're
meaningless or anything because I mean
people tend to feel very extremely
either standardized test scores is the
only way or they're complete garbage and
neither is true I mean they mean
something but they don't mean everything
and when teachers pay is determined by
the standardized test score of their
students I mean should I be teaching the
test of course yeah you got to keep your
job I mean you have to survive people
gonna want to survive it's and it's not
even like I mean the principals and
superintendents often don't have that
kind of flexibility I mean the places
that I've worked with that are excited
about creates if you're doing really
good stuff a lot of that is when people
up on high the superintendent both have
the flexibility and the interest and it
trickles down I mean one problem is that
that really good people end up getting
picked up for better jobs maybe sector
stuff and then boom Schuylkill school
goes right
back the way it is they bring in a
principal who wants things know why are
we doing this we need these test scores
it's um
and the funny thing is creativity adds
to test scores I mean there's some work
I'm doing with this school in Australia
with this guy Tim Paxton it's the
Geelong grammar school and they've been
looking at creativity and increasing
creativity and we just found out that
creativity helps predict their big test
score almost as much as grades do and
grades obviously and if I say hey you
get good grades you thinking to get a
good test score of course yeah but if I
say hey you're really creative you're
going to get a better test score yeah I
know maybe well creativity I remember
helped a lot of times especially that's
why I love when it came to the question
with the the written out ones because
you're like oh I didn't study I didn't
read anything but I got a chance you
know
it's like if you could find a way to be
crafty enough in that space when you had
a write out turn when you had a really
give an answer it was like what do you
think about this then you really had a
shot I felt like some time with
creativity you could really create
something you know you could yeah you
just had a chance you know you had a
chance to make something new you had a
chance to make something novel now one
thing so say if like you know this a lot
of times teachers up to teach based on
the test scores and and a lot of a lot
of people at a certain point they might
think oh well this a lot of extremely
creative people will drop out of formal
education or you know go you know public
school whatever school and still do
really well
I mean sometimes that even drives people
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't that
sometimes spur nor creativity more like
oh they don't understand me here in this
space I need to take my own path which
is kind of what creativity is sometimes
or it can they have to get lucky and
this is also where money comes in if you
have these people who feel that way and
they drop out but they're from a
well-off family that's one thing you end
up skew skew you end up losing more
people I think than you gain so to speak
because certainly you have people screw
this I'm dropping out I'm forming my own
company and you have these amazing
success stories but you also have the
people who have
they could have just been allowed to
flourish a little bit more in high
school would have realized wait I'm
passionate about this and I can express
myself this way and then would have
stuck with it and done something that
would have used their creativity and
contribute to the world you know it's
funny sometimes like I think some people
are really creative like people can be
creative and all type of way like the
wait somebody loves somebody could be
very creative oh yeah the way that
somebody you know I had an ex-girlfriend
who you know she would do really nice
things like leave a really nice note
sometimes if that was really sentimental
you know and I always thought it's not
creative but just to her idea of how to
create love and the show expressed that
was very creative I thought I'd argue
that is creative yeah it was created
yeah to me it was creative I guess it's
just not with the gym well we generally
think of when we think of creativity
exactly and that's one of the things
that limits us cuz I mean if you think
of okay what's creative I mean arts okay
somebody who paints their drawers or
composes and yes it is so science so
it's business and so all this stuff in
everyday life from writing love notes
magic magic oh god yeah magic animal
training oh I have an African Grey
parrot who I've taught to quote science
to lambs oh really
yeah freaks the hell out of our guests
to win this round
yeah you know I used to make love to a
girl in Denver if she had a great parrot
that would stay on my shoulder the whole
time let's go Kelly back in the day but
you know that her parrot still makes
sounds of the kind oh yeah oh yeah oh
man Wow the only sound it made was Ari
that's why you but Maudie's knows I'm
not really sexually good at it but oh so
does the parrot yeah oh the parrot
doesn't take up smoking like I did at
that time there's different times we had
a couple of other questions I want to
get to one video question that came in
here right here for you I also had a
question about drugs and creativity like
a lot of people think it kind of
inspires them or they need it to be
creative have you done research on that
do you see people are more creative with
alcohol or weed so there's been a lot of
research on this and oh yeah by a lot of
my friends even the informal kind your
producer kind of like the mental illness
question you're gonna find this study of
that study saying this or that but I'm
gonna just give them more overall thing
a lot of people will smoke weed drink or
do other stuff because they think it
will make them become creative and
people who for example who smoke pot
they think they're being more creative
so if you have a bunch of people and you
have this half we're going to give you
some weed in this half we're gonna give
you like oregano but it's tell you it's
weed and they all do something creative
the people who are on weed are gonna
think man we were just we did great this
is super creative but then you take what
they did and you show it to other people
the people on pot aren't more creative
mmm it's there's no difference it's just
a perception it's just perception and is
that perception only when they're under
the influence of potter when they're
high because when they sober up do they
think yeah I guess they just think oh
and I mean what of course I could not
speak from experience but how many of
you may look back on what they were
notes they took whatever or scribblings
when they were inebriated or on some
chemical and go what the hell was I
thinking or this is not the answer to
the world problem yeah I thought always
had a world bro that's so funny why one
time I was real real high and uh and man
what happened oh I thought I had this
great joke I drove by I wasn't driving
but I was in the car by myself going
forward of course and uh and I saw a
snake that like a snake a cartoon snake
on a billboard and here's the joke I
thought I thought
self I was gonna tell my friends oh I
saw a snake don't worry it was on a
billboard that was the joke and it was
and I thought at the time no young man I
wrote it down nine times to make sure
I've written it down because I don't
trust ink that much when I'm high you
know and then the next day I read it now
I was like oh my god this is the dumbest
thing ever
and that's when I was right then when it
was the dumbest thing ever
yeah so so overall that's that's the
truth but is there sometimes I mean
there's some times where somebody under
the influence could do something amazing
oh of course I mean it's also whenever
we study stuff there's this question of
whether something's related or whether
it actually causes it mmm I mean it's
the same way they say like if you give
infinite monkeys typewriters they'll
write Shakespeare I mean if you have a
whole bunch of people who are getting
high regularly which kind of describes
college people are gonna do really
creative stuff yeah it doesn't mean the
weed is there a reason why they're being
creative it's the same thing with mental
illness and creativity of course all
these people who have different mental
disorders may be incredibly creative it
doesn't mean there's any causal link and
if anything it may be that when things
are acting up it may be harder to create
or in a more positive way the creativity
may help them cope in and feel better
but it's not some romantic Vincent van
Gogh cutting off his ear you know and
you know I have you know yeah I've done
37 shots of vodka I'm going to create
the world's great novel it doesn't
really work that way maybe you're drunk
and writing the world's great novel but
probably not probably we importantly
father's an alcoholic who also wrote and
so a lot of times they marry the two
that it was you know there's definitely
a romantic romantic ization that happens
over time with almost anything really I
feel like we almost romanticize anything
so you're gonna take the fact that he
probably had alcoholism and then put it
with the fact that he wrote a lot and
next thing you know he's this great guy
who's sitting behind a bottle of scotch
and we're not really thinking about all
the other alcohol
who maybe would have been amazing but
who were passed out in their own vomit I
mean that's Ole Miss universities where
they don't hurt University of
Mississippi it really is sorry oh yeah a
shout out to campuses there but you know
what's because I used to worry you know
I don't do drugs or alcohol and I used
to worry that if I stopped doing those
that I wouldn't be able to be creative
and it's a fear of a lot of people and
there's no evidence of that just as
there's no evidence
similarly a lot of people are worried
about taking like prescription drugs for
anxiety depression that does not hurt
creativity really and that's I think
that too sometimes that's funny I do
there's no answer and it's so important
to realize that because people often
won't seek help you can't be creative
after you're dead right that definitely
sees his creativity I mean and if you're
suffering even if you look at the most
scary or typical of you know the mad
geniuses or whatever are the people with
extreme depressions or manias like
Howard Hughes maybe he was an extreme
case but yes I suppose I just say
extreme cases at the most extreme was
not when they were being their most
creative but if you're going up and down
at the peaks in the valleys you're still
not creating if it is always worth it
both my life point but also even a
creativity point to get yourself better
yeah I mean
what is there something inside of us
then you think I'd like a like a like a
man versus world level or something that
makes us think that having pain or
something will give us creativity do you
think it's some we want something to
have a reason for existing and had
things happen and that sucks and bad
things happen to us and that sucks if we
can make something come out of it okay I
had a shitty childhood but I write about
it or paint about it
therefore it was worth it mm-hmm so
there's an inspiration there a lot of
inspiration come from struggle a lot of
creativity does creativity come from
struggle it can absolutely but not only
from like it's not it's not not enough
so to put yourself through this struggle
I say you know so it's like I mean yes
if you grew up with these hardships that
can absolutely be an inspiration the
same way you know if you went through a
period of making bad decisions but it's
not a reason to make more bad decisions
or to do more things I say because it
just doesn't we want it to make sense
because then whatever stupid mistakes or
this relations if I can work us exactly
and I mean I wish life was that easy you
know I mean yeah it's nice if it
justifies for us as we're getting better
if we use it as like oh man yeah all
that behind me I'm glad that's behind me
now and I'm using that as like mum as a
motivation or inspiration or momentum to
do something different now absolutely
but if we're using it as well I should
probably stop doing this but it's making
me creative that's not helpful yeah
that's just a bad that's that's just not
the truth you know yeah what do we have
here Nick here's a beautiful little lady
right there could have fixed her hair
but [ __ ] it
she wrote that I didn't hey James my
name is Renee from Pennsylvania
and I was hoping that you could cover
the different types of creativity I'm
just assuming that it's almost like
different types of intelligence and if
it is maybe something that the different
types of creativity can do better than
the other types almost like a career
path or something like that or if you
can expand on the different types just
in general I'd be great thanks thank you
absolutely so there are a ton of these
different theories about stuff I'm just
going to pick a few really kind of
important stuff okay so you had the idea
of divergent thinking and that's being
able that's a type of creativity when
you're coming up with a whole bunch of
ideas mm each what you might think is
brainstorming oh yeah and that is really
good at the beginning of a creative of a
project there's what's sometimes called
convergent thinking or idea evaluation
and that sounds really unsexy because
choosing your best idea that doesn't
sound creative but that ability is also
incredibly important mmm because you can
come up with 30 ideas but you don't have
time in your life to pursue all 30 right
and figuring out okay these two are the
ones that are the best the most creative
the ones that I think can work that is
its own ability and process there is
what's sometimes called associative
thinking and that's mean these different
concepts or thoughts and there's often a
fairly obvious connection but trying to
think it was many different connections
as you can so like if I say cow there's
30 words they're probably right away
coming into your head and then that you
know Moo no boy yeah making okay how
remote can I go
how much can I think of things other
people aren't gonna think of these are
all different types
of what we might call like creative
thinking there's also a lot of stuff
involved in the creative personality one
huge thing is being open to experiences
this is wanted to try new foods wanting
to do new things wanting to just has me
experiences when you say what the hell I
mean I'm gonna try this even though I
haven't done it for some people is
traveling for other people it's wanting
to get into nature
there's also openness to ideas and
that's wanted to challenge yourself
intellectually that's wanting to debate
people it's wanting to problem-solve but
it's also being willing to accept that
you might be wrong hmm so openness to
experience tends to be related a bit
more to art's openness to intellect a
bit more assigns e-business stuff
[Music]
another component that sometimes will
happen but for idea generation is
problem finding we're so used to being
given the problem often were solving the
wrong problem yeah oh yeah I mean that's
you could call it I call it the
government any any time you want
throughout history I feel like Hollywood
does that a lot of times I think they're
always everybody thinks they're
proactive they're very reactive and
they're always solving a problem that I
feel like is eight months too late I
feel like I mean everybody yeah one
successful movie does something and they
come out with 30 movies just like it
yeah it's let's say that all your
friends are like you know Theo you're
just not that funny there's a bunch of
different problems you might be wanting
to address one of okay maybe you're not
funny maybe your friends are just
[ __ ] right who knows you got to find
out what the problem is and it all could
be the problem yeah a little bit but so
often does jump to something where I
mean if you realize oh I'm not making an
money to be able to still live in LA
there's a lot maybe you're okay I'm
gonna work more and make more money or
I'm gonna cut expenses if somebody's
been hacking your account and it's
dealing 2,000 bucks a month you're off
solving these problems and n it it's
still you're still getting screwed right
you're solving problems you might not
even have because you're not seeing the
a different problem I didn't see that so
there's even creativity when you're
looking for what the problem is
oh yeah and and in real life it's like a
doctor trying to treat a patient you got
the symptoms and I mean certainly yeah
there's the old saying that you look for
horses and not zebras
but sometimes it's a zebra yeah and
being able to do that not jumping in
with both feet and ending up wasting all
your time and resources on solving the
wrong thing that's a new problem right
there if you do that yeah I just made a
whole new problem I know we had um we
had a met dr. Jordan Peterson had a
theory about creativity yeah it was just
you know his idea of creativity was that
in order for something to technically be
creative it has to be something new
mm-hmm so I guess I'm curious one
example I could give would be say you're
a fan of music and you'd make a cover
song of somebody else's original music
you've then created something new that
wasn't there before but is it really
creative what I'd argue is that just
like before I was not much different
when I was talking my different creative
processes there's also different types
of creative contributions you might say
where you have some that are the
shockingly new oh my god this changes
the field and everything is different
and that's what we often will think
about you know when we think about you
know Tesla or inline roller skates any
of that the iPhone all that's the iPhone
but this almost creates a B that we know
is
usually just like a little step forward
and I mean so okay you know that water
bottle that you have that is a slightly
cheaper version of a different water
bottle right that was a little bit of an
innovation or that design is made so
that it gives you a better angle when
you tilt the bottle back these are all
modifications is this shocking
creativity
no but it's incremental it's a little
small bit and then you have this almost
replication creativity where you're
doing things in your way and that and
this would be you know you're doing a
cover of a song or you painting your own
version of something you see like happy
and it is own version of The Simpsons
and I was actually and this is a great
example I mean is this creative I think
it a really creative
is it shockingly new well it's somebody
else's style it still counts I mean it's
one of the things I often will come back
to because people and I'm sometimes I
feel like a broken record here they'll
say oh I'm not creative whatever and
some of it is they'll think well yeah I
did my own version of it but that's not
new and okay maybe you're not a genius
so you know I'm not saying people are
all geniuses it still counts it still
counts yeah and you get you get credit
or whatever you want to say for that I
mean there is um you know the Lonely
Island song with a comma no no that's
what t-pain's yeah they've just had as I
would say in my class to be delicate
they've just been physically intimate
with somebody okay
and they keep giving all these
situations still counts still counts
wears a bag on her head
still you know you're doing your little
doodle and you're not showing to anybody
still counts you're you know if you're
telling a joke and your own way that you
heard another comedian say assuming that
you're giving credit um still counts
you're skewing your own spin on it
you're you're making it a little bit
better you write in fan fiction or
whatever you're doing your own version
of something it still counts and you're
creative it doesn't mean you can't
improve you should
right it counts and give yourself credit
for that yeah if you build a building
even though somebody's already built a
built a building and you're not Franklin
Lloyd Wright was he a building maker
yeah okay then
yeah still count so you still built the
building you still did something you
don't see he so did something
magnificent something that's hard to do
and something that's still gonna be
there is it hard for us to do they say
everything has been done I'm sure you
get approached with this kind of
question a lot I mean you think we're
getting close no I mean back in the
eighteen hundreds the guy from the
Patent Office while everything that
could possibly be invented has been
invented listen an [ __ ] cuz everybody
keeps saying that he's my pessimist I
mean we always end up going in different
directions I mean if you go back to the
60s and you try to see okay well what do
they think the future was gonna be like
it was all flying cars and the moon and
living you know okay that didn't happen
but we can communicate with anybody
instantly you can have a buddy who lives
in Spain and you can talk to him every
day for free yeah whatever I mean nobody
ever would have fallen out in the 60s
they're getting probably some guy
thinking that it'll just be different
right we may not know the new medium we
may not know do you think there's still
a lot we can learn scientifically
there's still a lot to learn out there
do you think there's like oh yeah that
word you you because sometimes I feel
like oh we've we've kind of figured it
out everything we got the periodic table
of elements we know everything at tier
we know we know all the recipe items you
think there's more out there I think
there's a lot more out there than
already is I think that I mean it's true
for I think anything but we know a very
small little bit and I mean studying
creativity is not curing cancer is not
in nuclear physics or whatever right or
even close but but if the world of
possibility I feel like as part of it
was creativity and just trying to figure
out you know what makes people more
creative what are the people who are
creative what do they have in common how
can we help it how can we help these
people how can we encourage it how can
we
figure out I mean just how do you get
feedback to somebody it's get them to be
more creative I mean if you're cute
harsh yeah they're gonna go okay I guess
I just suck at it
but if you're too lenient they're never
gonna learn there's gonna keep sucking
obviously there's somewhere that medium
point there are so many of these
questions that if you actually look okay
well what does the research say I mean
even it's me like you know the
creativity in marijuana that's such a
everybody thinks that doesn't that
certain questions that you know people
always want to know and it's been
studied but we're talking twenty
twenty-five studies not four hundred and
I mean how do you measure creativity
right I mean I have some answers but
there's a whole bunch of different
creativity tests and they're all good
for this bad for that and if you have
thirty studies
five of them and use this measure and
five use that one and six for a skin
people what they think and so you can't
even really combine all of it and so if
you're trying to ask a really basic
questions like okay well are people who
are creative in physics are they the
same people who are creative in music I
mean short answer is probably not but we
don't quite know we're still figuring
out or what are the things that will
kind of predict who's the creative
scientist who's the creative businessman
or businesswoman who's a creative
teacher or if they find some tangent
between physics and music that's
suddenly the whole playing field is
different and suddenly you're physicians
are damn you know kid rock or whatever
you know and and that such where's that
and the funny thing is a badge the type
of creativity that scares the crap out
of people like the little incremental
stuff do you know we're making this cop
show except now the cops are all
professional circus clowns you know
that's like a little bit forward
nobody's scared of that everybody likes
that it's when you're talking well hey
maybe when we do surgery we should be
you know Megadeth listening to Megadeth
or we should be doing it and using our
feet instead of hands I mean that's the
type of creativity of stairs a crap edit
and they don't like it they don't like
creative people they say they do but
they don't well then there must be such
a difference then between somebody who's
able to think creatively and somebody
who can't there must be all right or
maybe when it comes to ideas I feel
scared come to that mind instead of
can't I'd say won't I think all the can
but it's risky it's taking a risk I mean
are you willing to risk pissing people
off or looking stupid or losing money or
all this stuff in order to put forward
this idea and so many of us aren't some
money must take the safe choice so many
of us I mean it's a hell of a lot easier
to do it's been done or just to tweak it
a little bit I mean if you wanted to you
could give the exact same comedy routine
every single time and you'd be fine the
rest of your life and there are a lot of
people that sounds pretty great they
don't have to think but just when yeah
but it's certainly yeah I would lose
yeah you'd go crazy I'm crazy you know
you have that need to create not
everybody has the need but others had
the need don't know how others had the
need but don't have the resilience don't
have the support I mean I was lucky out
of really encouraging a family you know
and folks are psychologists I had really
good teachers like a lot of people who
study creativity often oh they had to
stay struggled in school or wherever you
I was lucky I don't mean like I was a
great student but I really liked my
teachers and I was supported and I was
lucky I mean there are people who don't
have these advantages and it's you got
to be brave and resilient and then push
back and keep going and it means defying
defying other people defying yourself to
mean having all these people always say
you're wrong you're wrong yeah or having
people not understand you as well it's
like a way that you take
you know it but to you it comes off as
you're wrong you know just people yeah I
think people not understanding you as
well can really lead you to can really
lead you to sometimes refine what you're
trying to say which is what's necessary
anyway but it's like now it's not
necessarily saying you're wrong it's
getting personal about you yeah you know
how it's gotten wild out there
I mean you if you're making a joke on
social media I mean that's what you do
that's how you create not just social
media right but it's not just this one
thing people just go yeah I don't think
I don't think that's funny
but you also people you're an [ __ ]
damn I didn't know that yeah I just I
mean I knew I loved it look I'll accept
that I'm not funny today but I will not
accept that I'm an [ __ ] yeah that
judgment it's so easy to be right there
on the to judge something that's not in
front of you you know we had her buddy
recently in the comedy community that
like made some remarks after Kobe Bryant
died and it really had a sharp
backlash and everybody was you know
people that didn't even know him
suddenly were furious and it was really
all the people that kind of knew him I
think maybe were like oh we understand
it so this is the way he operates
sometimes this was not a he didn't do a
good job here as far as everybody was
concerned maybe a couple of Voldemort's
out there that he really impressed you
know but on a large scale a lot of
people heard about him for the first
time and we're and this was a bad way
for it to happen you know as far as him
feeling okay and stuff and I'm certain
hurt his feelings but yeah it's like
people aren't really understanding these
days on social media is not a real place
to be understanding it's not very human
and we always assume intent and this is
this isn't even a social media thing I
mean if you're driving and somebody cuts
you off
you're not thinking oh maybe they're
driving their pregnant wife to the
hospital and then they're desperate to
get there you're thinking that guy's an
[ __ ] and it was intentional and he
looked at me and said screw you
yeah but when you cut somebody off
you're like whoops that was a mistake
Pope don't know it they'll be okay with
it they know
two different worlds going on when it
comes to creativity do you think about
like do you think that there's a higher
power sometimes or something that puts
ideas into us like a lot of times I feel
like we're not been my most creative I
don't feel like it has anything to do
with me I feel like I'm just kind of
like a conduit or whatever septic Oh for
something yeah like oh there's no way I
came up with that idea really I mean
certainly whatever you believe in you if
you can just let yourself whether it's
your unconscious whatever letting your
brain be a little open there's a reason
why people get really good ideas in the
shower or when you derive it because
your body's occupied and you're doing
something and so you're not necessarily
distracted and your brains just open and
your mind is wandering and that's one's
whether it's your subconscious whether
it's God whatever it is putting ideas
the muse making sure you have those
moments when you allow the insights to
come as huge and if you're always
boom-boom-boom-boom
you're not gonna have that time you
could have anything trying to sprout
ideas and they won't they won't take
root yeah you got it
I mean you got to make sure you have the
FIR the fertile soil out there right
yeah you could have the Archangel of the
dang universe trying to fly out of your
out of your damn septum but if you're
always on Instagram you might miss yeah
I mean just letting that moment of
reflection you know everything in
moderation to a degree guys anything
else you wanted to chime in now this is
fascinating though I love to go back
over your own work to kind of spark that
creativity I think that's like really
actionable thing people can take away
from it is what going over your own work
to spark creativity when you're feeling
like your creative juices run out I
think that's something everybody can and
kind of adapt yeah of almost it really
blew my mind when I realized that
you know and not even realize but it's
just so funny just in the past maybe
month I've like man I don't want to
write this gratitude listed specifically
what it is and gratitude such as it's a
real such a real feeling and a visceral
thing that I I need to feel a lot of
times to try and just feel OK in my day
and then I go back and I'm like oh man
and I'll read him and it's like oh then
I'm there it's almost like I've already
made the list I get the feeling as if
I've already made the list and it's a
real feeling it's not doesn't feel like
a SIBO either and I mean it's for life
but for creativity a certain kindness
and I mean kindness to yourself also
when you're going back and looking at
your old stuff I mean yeah you're always
me a little critical but be kind to your
younger self when you're thinking I mean
it's why co-creation is such an amazing
thing I mean one of my favorite things
as a researcher is to collaborate mmm
you know and then I hate that have you
found the right collaborator and of
course you got what you got you got
these two guys right here also
oh no Nick is wonder if I mean Nick is
wonderful and we did we probably do it a
ton I do it a ton without even realizing
it hi there I have some fear about
something about it makes me feel
uncomfortable
you know I just like what I don't know I
don't want to it's like I'm afraid to
share not afraid to share I'm afraid I'm
trying to trying to think out the rest
of this feeling I'm afraid to like have
yeah I can almost figure out what it is
sometimes I really have to be able to
get right on the feeling I don't like
it's like a trust thing I think you know
it's like I really do I trust this
person enough with like my do I trust
somebody else enough to to share the
things that are most important to me
which are like my ideas you know and are
they going to reject them and is it
rejection or is it having them take the
ideas and turn them into something you
don't like I think it's at the courts
rejection I think that they're not gonna
like them or that they're and if they
don't like them then they don't like me
and so it's my own attachment to my own
ideas as well then and yet there's
people you trust enough to share you
don't ya think of it as collaboration so
is it that you'd be worried about let's
say collaborating with somebody who you
who you believe either would have we're
being rejected by them would be
particularly painful yeah probably the
probably it goes back to other
relationships in my life or it's like I
just have a lot of fear about that you
know and so but then it's it sticks even
though sometimes and work and stuff you
know I don't want to I have to do it my
I'm only used to doing it my way you
know I'm just scared to not do it my way
there's a danger there of course cos if
you just listen to those words do i I'm
afraid to do it my to not do it my way
and you wanted to do it this one way
there's a certain danger there well we
miss out on a lot of probably
collaboration I missed out on working
together with people are there people
who you know you know appreciate and
like your idea it's Navis established
that who you would trust obviously again
there are people but people who you
normally would have dismissed
collaborating with but yeah probably so
so really it's just as strong fear
that's not really
it's not really serving me and you're
asking if fear helps it hurts creativity
I mean I think in a lot of ways it can
hurt it because we got to take risks any
risks are scary you know I mean [ __ ] I'm
a professor I'm not a performer this was
a little scary particularly given I have
lost you know three of my front teeth
they're gonna know got him I sound like
Daffy Duck what does the best part of it
those awesome dude if you could shoot
that and land it in a lady's wineglass
out of dinner dude I could get you a job
somewhere New York tonight you could
like one of those magicians that goes
around the tables you know my teeth now
is that the three of hearts and my teeth
in your hand
why yes it is your teeth and now they're
back here get your teeth out of my
wife's I believe it buddy oh yeah no I
guess you're right I mean that fear just
really prevents me from having that
co-creation you know and it's
interesting hearing you say that that's
one of your favorite kinds is that
collaborative because that's that makes
me really think I'm missing out on some
cool stuff and certainly not with
everybody it's not like oh it's all one
being happy you know but there is a
three four five six people who and again
not Nicki all at once but I find elevate
my ideas mmm and they make me think of
stuff that I haven't really thought
about before I mean one of my main
collaborator does a guy named Vlad
everybody should have a good friend
named Vlad he's awesome he's brilliant
and he does cultural stuff all about how
we interact with each other in
socio-cultural a lot of the stuff I do
is more individual so okay well what is
you know Doug is creative and Bill is
less creative and Sally is the most
creative how are they different the same
whereas Vlad's more interested in how
can they all be creative together and
when I was first like oh man I don't
know about that stuff and he's one of my
favorite collaborators not because he
gets me to just think in new ways and it
was hard at first you know and you have
to kind of give up a little bit of some
your assumptions and involves trust yeah
um yeah I can imagine it it almost
sounds cool because then you're like wow
this person could get me to think
different and ways if a if I already
feel like I'm a creative person if
something that I pride kind of been
myself there's not a lot of things but
that's a thing then if they could get me
to be creative in different ways that I
don't even know I mean it is pretty
tempting
yeah I have a friend named Aaron and
he's like my most create he's like he's
kind of business minded a lot of times
but even in that space he helped he gets
me to think so many different ways a lot
of times yeah I think just being a
little more open to it and it's not like
it means now you got to only co-create I
mean you still you there are some things
that will always feel like okay these
these are my personal ideas I want to
marinate and do it my own way there's
other stuff and maybe it's a stuff you
couldn't figure out quite how to make be
amazing like okay I like this idea but I
don't know to do with it and so I put
over here even if funny how ideas you've
had I mean there's little ideas that I
had 15 18 years ago and suddenly they'll
come into play when I meet someone or
something or or I'll see a new medium
and I'd be like oh that's why this thing
has been spinning in my head for so long
it's just waiting for this place to land
that didn't even exist yet it's kind of
amazing isn't it that to me is
fascinating man it's like almost the way
the galaxy is like you have these things
spinning around and we don't know really
what the moons are I mean we have an
idea but suddenly all of a sudden you
know somebody comes through on a
battleship and there a moon collector
and then we're like oh now I know why
these things are out there this guy's
here to pick them up you know you just
don't know it's like yeah it's pretty
fascinating it's funny how like there's
a point when I like if I if I think like
a virtual reality something I'm I've
still to me right relative I know it's
been around for a while the
possibilities for being creative in
virtual reality are amazing and like
we're only starting to really move with
that really I feel like it's the worst
thing for why because it's not me being
creative I feel like I feel like I used
to have the video game inside of me
and now I'm like just looking inside of
the game and looking inside of somebody
else's imagination or like a company's
imagination someone more like that but I
mean the ones and there's more and more
stuff developing out there but the ones
that are showing you things you wouldn't
have seen but then not prescribing not
saying like because I agree there's some
games when it's okay I depress the left
button you got to do that that mean it's
gonna be fun but I'm this stuff when
you're truly exploring and what there's
enough open stuff out that you're
connecting things they're just you know
you can play impossible instruments mmm
you can make art that wouldn't be
possible in the real world you can
co-create with people and all around the
world I mean it's yeah they have a cool
app where you can sing with Asian people
and whenever you want and they sing and
you sing the same song but it's in
different languages and then they mix
them together I mean I love folk I mean
that is pretty cool did I'll give you
that it's pretty cool yeah man I mean
that's one thing about creativity it's
like we stopped this conversation it
keeps on going and two weeks now you're
having thoughts you know like it's also
one reason why I like the collaboration
so much because my internal dialogue
it's pretty good you know
yeah but the dialogue with other people
that and then you think and then you
think oh what would they have said about
that
and well okay I decided not to take this
risk as I'm worried about that and I get
that but how would it look if I did
what's the worst that could happen if I
did you start branching out and thinking
I mean yeah I mean that's what yeah I
mean yeah it's a connection there's so
much creativity in that not having to be
creative alone you know I I one more
question for you I know like you know a
lot of our listeners struggle with
pornography addiction and stuff like
that do you find that there's been a lot
of studies and stuff done on how like
pornography like really damages like the
creativity of ones like sex
libido I feel like cuz he stuff to
create these worlds in my head you know
which would then resonate in my body I
would feel like I mean I think so much
of it comes down to your ability to
control and that if any addiction to a
degree out of control is gonna limit you
whatever that is I mean if you're
addicted to food and you blow up you
know if you're watching so much
pornography that when you think of sex
your mind instantly goes okay this is
what happens mmm Dania you're probably
less creative in sex if you're looking
at it as an inspiration or hey what if I
try that with my partner or whatever
mm-hmm not necessarily so that
perception then is really and what
you're able to certain amount of
self-control and in terms of it I don't
mean it's actually I mean in a creative
way yeah in that seeing all these things
but wine okay I wanna put my own spin on
this I want to and also not having that
into what's the destination of what's
the journey you know if it's okay I am
watching pornography and mission
accomplished and that's all I need to do
then yeah your own sex life with your
partner is not going to flourish right
if it's inspiration if it's okay this is
part of the journey and I'm gonna I'm
gonna take a few things from here maybe
bring it introduce them every year see
how it goes maybe see if they're open to
it I mean that's a good point
one of the tried and true ways of being
creative is it take different genres or
things and you combine them mix them up
you know I'm taking this from that just
from that what had a mash-up yeah you
know I mean applesauce yeah an apple pie
Western in space
oh yeah thank you you know yeah like
Star Wars or something that was a bad
one but I used to think yeah a good
space Western did ever have one Star
Trek was it a space Western and we're
really was kind of
they went from let me you take that and
you put that in the old frontiers days
in a covered wagon it's the same story
yeah
and instead of aliens just people from
Fresno or whatever yeah and a lot of the
bat a lot of the places that win even
look like Fresno a little bit I mean it
was just a Western they put it in space
I think that's all we got that's great
dr. James company uh you're teaching now
at UConn yes I'm a professor at
University of Connecticut and doing a
whole bunch of research on creativity
and give so many books and if I don't
we'll put a lot of that in the intro
whenever we bring you up got my website
and working on number differently
layperson books and I know after a while
doing research you more and more having
again it's the heart attack like I want
to do stuff in the real world I want
actually help people be creative instead
of just you know well it's interesting
because yeah it's like a lot of people
don't go to a school book place you
don't go to a campus bookstore to get
books you know a lot of times you go to
another you know you'll go to other
outlets and stuff to get books and so
yeah um yet creativity is my favorite
thing man so I appreciate you coming
here until hi every day and and I've
often felt that people who are really
successful in different areas are a lot
no more know a lot more about creativity
than they think they do hmm
comedies are the top ones hmm I was
quite excited about this because just to
hear your thoughts can I pick your brain
a little bit oh thanks man yeah I just
always thought like I was just very
aware like too much sometimes and so I
was always creating like different
scenarios of what could go on because I
was aware like what was happening so
much like okay this person is over there
this is going on you know the Sun is
setting this is happening right now what
are we gonna do what's gonna happen you
know mom's coming mom is feeling like
this every you know just was always so
many things to like balance that the
awareness was always heightened I felt
like when I was young and so that made
me suddenly when I was sitting there
riding with a piece of paper and
thinking
about things there was all these things
were there was an awareness for them in
the page it was an awareness for
everything could be a character you know
like the son had a had a you know it had
aspirations and you know and and the
mailman
you know maybe played jazz you know
there was just different things going on
when whenever life happened you observe
but sometimes became exhausting though
just the other side of it we were just
overwhelmed by constantly worried about
what people are thinking and feeling and
not knowing that you're okay so put you
in like an unsafe space you know so the
creativity you build in it's very
negative almost because your brain
creates a lot of like scary situations
it's the danger I mean some of its can
be perfectionism some of it can be me
imagination can be used for less
positive things if you're worrying about
what could be and then if you have a if
you're very creative you can imagine all
this stuff I mean how many times the
people said well what's the worst that
could happen well if you're if you can
imagine all that stuff it's harder yeah
I mean to me it's yeah yeah or if you're
it a lot somebody who's thinking a lot
and so much of that is is being able
channel it being able to okay well I
know I have all these ideas ping-pong in
my brain the more that you can express
channel in these more proactive ways you
know the more you can let the other
parts your brain kind of just yeah it
really is like petting a cat like stay
there but he'll stay there yeah anything
else you wanted to talk about James so
much but not but hopefully had another
time in the future I would love to have
you back in Chris huh sue and there's so
much stuff that I mean I'd love to
listen back and even it come up with new
things to think of yeah because there's
so much just this creativity has to be
good or bad
can it be bad you know all sorts of
stuff that well yeah I mean some people
created some of the worst [ __ ] ever the
blimp
that machine oh yeah member Hitler
and but that and that's a question was
he creative right it's so funny because
I thought about that earlier today a
little bit I was thinking about what it
what could be creativity and I mean yeah
that's a risk of creativity isn't there
Fame it like Pandora's Box isn't that a
thing of mmm it's basically just a thing
of Arts and Crafts somebody just cracked
open a little box of Michael's craft
store I feel like is it that something
good or back you come out of there and
[Music]
it's creativity is not creativity is not
good or bad inherently it's like it's
being smart good or bad I mean it's good
for you but if everybody was smarter
would the world be a better place know
everybody nobody would be driving a
Corvette either I'll tell you that if
everybody's more creative the world be a
better place yeah bet maybe but then it
might become that's not everybody's
trying to out create like out creative
each other at such a level where it's
just getting ridiculous as well as you
know you'd have all the serial killers
be that much more creative you'd have
all the people being that more creative
on how to screw you over in business
deal
oh I'm either worse we can't handle it
anymore out here I mean the studio
executives would be that much more
creative and well you can assign the
rights for this I mean you have to think
of it all those layers well if everybody
just becomes more creative and that
means a bad people do too and it's that
good as a bad I mean some of it's how we
choose to use our creativity in this
practical way I mean like what we almost
started with if you wanted to use your
creativity to make people happy make me
feel better yeah I mean that's a
wonderful positive thing there's other
people out there who aren't going to be
thinking that yeah that's the dark arts
that's what we go and fight all the time
it's uh yeah sometimes it's like and
then when things become more of a
business - it gets less yeah it's still
the same but it just gets I don't know
it gets a little different you know
but that's okay just I think some of it
sometimes is a level of Correction and
stuff like that but yeah when money gets
involved in creativity then what happens
it impacts why you're being creative
sometimes and that's the scary part yeah
I mean because so many of us are
creative because we love it and there's
other reasons but yet once money starts
playing you know and again not that
money is bad money not great money is
really not in favor I'm going to keep
you warm in the winter and cool in the
summer that's what they say but but yeah
you're on the audience but that struggle
there's some value there's some of it
you just have so many more paints in
your and you're sure when Williams when
you got that struggle bellman you know
when you have some when you can find
that motivation but like you're saying
like that balance you know yeah we're
gonna work on keeping the balance and
dr. Kaufman we'd love to have you bad
that I would love to come back awesome
thank you so much for coming you bet
thank you for having me yeah
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my my I can feel it enough
thought it's gonna take
a little town for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]